the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible]
welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today written
Nancy Rosenblum, who is a Harvard University
Department of Government,
Professor Emerita, who wrote the book. A lot
of people are saying co-written with Russell
Muirhead a Nancy, so great to have you on
the program.
I'm delighted to be with you, David.
So I think an interesting place to start would
be, we talk a lot about conspiracy theories,
conspiratorial thinking on the program. We've
looked at some of the psychological mechanisms
that impact people, uh, getting into this
type of thinking. But one thing we've not
discussed so much is whether from a sort of
objective empirical, a a point point of view,
conspiratorial type thinking is increasing
in society. So let, let's maybe start there.
Do we have any strong evidence one way or
the other about whether in general this type
of thought is more prevalent today than it
has been in the past?
I don't think we have, um, more evidence of
its prevalence. I think we can say two things
with, with some confidence. One is that the
spread of conspiracy thinking probably has
increased because of the Internet. It's costless
and speedy to, um, spread these kinds of rumors
or claims. And that gives us a reason. It's
hard to count on the Internet, as you probably
know, but it gives us reason to think that
more people are at least exposed to these
things, whether or not they're true believers.
I think the other thing I can say with confidence,
because it's the theme of my book, is that
there is a new kind of conspiracy thinking
out there today and it's not conspiracy theory
as we understand it, it's conspiracy ism without
the theory the two have become decoupled and
this really is a new and malignant phenomenon
in politics.
It's brought conspiracy thinking in from the
fringe right into the White House in the halls
of power. And it has I think, a different
significance in different effect than classic
conspiracy theory. Well, so can we first define
the difference? What would be and maybe examples
would be good when we talk about conspiracy
theorizing of versus conspiracy FISM what?
What is the distinction between the two? Well,
the conspiracy theory is a theory. We should
take that part of the phrase seriously. That
is, it's offering an explanation of things
and conspiracy theories. Theorists do a lot
of rigorous work. They collect the dots, they
amass evidence, they find patterns in this
evidence. They develop a grand narrative and
sometimes these conspiracy theories are actually
true and sometimes they're completely fantastic
and unwarranted. And often there are vexing
mix of the two. But in any case, these people
are like researchers.
They are making an argument based on evidence
and they want you to think that this argument
is true, that the unintelligible, the previously
unintelligible has been made intelligible
by their findings. And that the unbelievable
has been made believable. So for example,
a conspiracy theorist has an account of the
real assassination of John F. Kennedy, right?
Or a conspiracy theory about, uh, the real
sources of the nine 11 attack. That it wasn't
a 19 men operating out of the remote quarters
of Afghanistan. It was the u s government
don't drones or whatever it was. So that's
a conspiracy theory. It's an explanation.
And in a way, conspiracy theorists reason
the same way. We all reason when we want to
make an argument about something that's happening
in the world, the new conspiracies and really
is entirely different. It's conspiracy with
that theory and it doesn't attempt to comply
or explain anything.
There are no dots, there are no patterns,
is no evidence, there's no argument. Instead,
what you have is a bare assertion. The election
is rigged, for example. Or, um, the Mueller
report is an attempted a coup d'etat. So it's
bare submission. Sometimes it takes the form
of, I'm just asking questions. You know what
I know is bad enough? People would say about
the birther conspiracy, uh, what I know is
bad enough, but I'm just asking questions.
What I really want us to know a lot more or
they, uh, or they take it takes the form of
a kind of attribution like some agent of government
is plotting something. It's an insidious plot.
It's clearly ominous. It's something worse
than sort of partisan bias or self interest,
but there's no explanation of who or why or
for what purpose. So it's conspiracies and
without, without the explanation. And there's
a way in which this conspiracy is without
the, uh, uh, explanation is very powerful.
Yeah. Well, I was going to ask, is one more
pernicious than the other or dangerous than
the other? Because you, you might imagine
that with a particular conspiracy theory,
you can at least attempt to take the theory
head on, present, uh, you know, a contradictory
narrative. Ask for that evidence. Ask what
might change your mind about this particular
theory? It seems that with conspiracy CISM
more generally, it could be more difficult
to disabuse someone of those beliefs.
I think that that's exactly exactly right.
Then I made the point earlier, the conspiracy
theory reasons, the way we reason these kinds
of bare assertions like the election is rigged,
are completely disorienting. They've just
orienting and unnerving because they, um,
they, they completely changed the, what it
means for us to know something because they
come without argument. They come just with
insistence and when we can't, uh, when, when
someone changes, as I say what it means to,
to know something and it's very hard to answer
it, the other thing that makes it much more
dangerous of course, is that it's coming from
the office of the president or from elected
representatives or, um, from, from governors
and so on. And of course from conspiracy entrepreneurs
who spread it. And this is the third thing
that makes it, I think I'm more potent than
conspiracy theory.
And that's that it uses the internet in a
different way. Conspiracy theorists use the
internet to find their dots in their evidence,
right? Architects and engineers for nine 11
truth look up the, uh, the escalating a temperature
of jet fuels, for example, or the capacities
and drones, whereas the new conspiracies used
the internet really very differently to, to
spread their ideas. And when you make a bare
assertion, it's easy to spread, right? You
can do it in 280 characters easily. You're
not offering an explanation. And they use
a sent to this theory as, as validation would,
validates it is not the argument would validates
it is a lot of people are saying, and that's
the title of the book. So, and you can in
a sense, count the number of retweets, likes,
or shares. And so you can say, a lot of people
are saying that the Obama administration tap
the phones of Trump tower during the campaign.
Yeah. I, my sense when I talked to conspiracy
theorists is that they do care and are genuinely
invested in the truth or falsity of what their
assertions are. Exactly. How, how does that
compare to conspiracy ism? Because with some
of these conspiracist, uh, ideas, I am less
convinced that those espousing the ideas are
actually invested in the truth, but rather
invested merely in the spread of the, of the
general notion for their benefit.
I think that that's very perceptive and knew
David and he was, he use how I understand
it. Um, when the president, for example, makes
conspiracist claim that, uh, the Justice Department
is planning accrued the people who follow
him, who was sent to it, who spread it, who
repeated, don't necessarily think that all
of the elements are, all of the facts have
to be true. They think that they are, the
phrase that we use is that this claim is true
enough. That is, it fits with their political
hostilities and political animosities and
political connections so that the story is
true enough. If you think that Hillary Clinton
is evil and does horrible things and lies
about it, then the pizzagate conspiracy, which
says that she's running a child sex trafficking
ring out of the basement of a pizza parlor
in northwest Washington DC. They don't necessarily
have to believe that it, all of those facts
are true.
What they believe is it's true enough. And
let me read you, um, because this confirms
your hypothesis here. Let me read you a couple
of quotes about what true enough really sounds
like. So Republican representative in Congress
was asked about the allegation that the Democratic
Party at actually conspired to create that
clash between white nationalists and um, uh,
protestors in Charlottesville in 1917. And
the representative said, I'm not saying it's
true, but I'm saying it's completely plausible.
Give another example. When Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is asked about Trump's tweet or the
video that fall asleep reported to show a
Muslim immigrant assaulting someone, she said,
whether it's a real video, the threat is real.
And this is the point that it's true enough.
Some probably there was some unbelievers who
we think every element of something like pizzagate
is true. And in fact in armed gunman went
to the pizza parlor and shot up the place
because he went to rescue the children. But
most I've been do not. I think that this new
conspiracy ism any assent to it. And the validation
do tweeting and liking and affirming and so
on is a sort of form of political participation.
Yeah. Well I was going to say
that there's this, uh, there's this, uh, rationalization
that often exists, which is it's less important
whether this is specifically true because
belief in this serves as sort of a means to
an end, even if this particular assertion
is not true. And I think that that's how a
lot of conspiracists rationalized continuing
to spread stuff that even they question the
truth of,
I think that's right. And so then the question
becomes why is this so dangerous? What's happening?
I mean, we could look back and say it's absurd.
We can say it's as new instead of malignant
form of political expression, but we haven't
gotten it why it's really dangerous, why we
should care about it and why I think it's
one of the most prominent and unders under
assessed elements of American politics today,
this spread conspiracy ism. And I think that
what it does besides disorienting us is to
deal legitimate foundational democratic institutions.
And I w the most obvious is all kinds of knowledge
producing institutions have been diligent,
amazed by these conspiracies plans. The most
obvious and publicized is fake news. Fake
News doesn't just say that there are erroneous
or making a partisan stories. Fake News really
says that there's a conspiracy and the mainstream
media to denigrate, um, the administration
and that that's, uh, that this news casters
are enemies of the people.
But that's just the most obvious every time.
When Trump says, for example, that he had
the biggest inaugural crowd in history and
then the national park service photographs
showed that it was a modest crowd. What did
he do? He said that the, that the national
parks service doctor, the photographs, this
is a conspiracy claim and an undermines the
meaning and the value in the authority of
the National Parks Service. And the same thing
is true when he attacks the FBI or national
intelligence estimates with the national intelligence
director, Dan Coats issued his annual threat
assessment and said the climate change had
become a security threat for a variety of
reasons. The administration said he should
go back to school. What does the national
intelligence director now, so we have this
cumulative de-legitimized can have all kinds
of knowledge producing institutions and we
need them because you cannot make political
decisions and policy decisions without some
confidence that facts matter and conspiracy
ism is a better, more permanent, more powerful,
I think way of dealer Judah Mating these institutions
and the vats that they assess then lies. Trump's
lies calming go for example, they're fact
checked or they're not, but they're hard to
keep up with. I think the New York Times said
something like 10,000 recently. Yeah, his
conspiracist plans and the ones that are supported
by his followers and by many Republicans today,
um, they're pretty permanent. The same ones
go on and on. They have traction. He comes
back to them again and again and they do this
delegitimization.
Nancy, in the limited time we have left, I'd
love to just briefly here, what are the techniques,
if there are any, that you have found to be
effective in getting people away from conspiracist
beliefs and that sort of conspiracies framework?
Well, to some extent it's the same as, as
combating lies. I mean there's a kind of fact
checking the can go on. I would insist that
you will never get at the people who are supporting
Trump and other conspiracies claims for political
reasons. Right? This is, it might have been
trenched polarization. So the question is
can you immunize or give some confidence to
the rest of the public who really it gets
sort of disoriented by these wacky claims
and who, uh, I think turnoff politically and
it's really just as I think a matter of giving
people confidence in their common sense because
that's what these conspiracies claims do.
They do legitimate institutions and diligent
many political parties and political opposition,
but they do it in a way that offends common
sense. That's why were so disoriented by it
all. And I think some confidence in common
sense that comes about by speaking truth to
conspiracy ism is the best thing we can do.
We've been speaking with Nancy Rosenbloom,
Harvard University, Department of government
professor. Yeah,
Marita who wrote the book. A lot of people
are saying co-written of course, with Russell
Muirhead. Nancy, such a pleasure having you
on. I appreciate it. And you were a great
question, David. Thank you.